hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 60 of game
programming so I've got a new microphone
this time again this isn't a headset mic
this is a different microphone so
hopefully you guys will will enjoy the
change in audio quality let me know what
you think of this microphone and
hopefully hopefully eventually you know
we'll find something that you guys like
but um today on episode 60 we're gonna
take a look at creating the spawn levels
so level design is honestly one of my
favorite aspects of game programming but
it's also the author I should say game
development but also it's one of the
things that if you don't get right it
doesn't feel like a game like obviously
it's still obviously still feels like a
game but what I mean by that is it just
it doesn't feel it if you don't get this
right it's not going to convey the
feeling that you want to to the to the
player to the audience so that's why you
know getting this right is crucial but
the site at the same time it's very fun
so if I bring over our hierarchy which
of course is this is the cell root
directory of our game we've got the
resources folder and in the textures
folder and then we've got levels so
actually let's pull levels out of
textures I'm not sure what ass there but
in the results as Walter will have
levels and will have textures so we've
currently got this level dot PNG file
and that's all fine we're not gonna mess
with that what we are going to do though
is create a new PNG files together so
I'm gonna open paint.net paint.net and
in paint.net this is where we're gonna
create a file so at the moment I have no
clue what these spawn levels should look
like alright so I'm just gonna go off
the top of my head and hopefully you
know be good first thing I need to do is
obviously it's set a canvas size so hmm
one level let me just think mmm I might
go with something like let's just say
like 40 tiles long maybe like 40 tiles
wide sorry and maybe like like 7075
tiles high something something like that
right so it's kind of like that and let
me just say I beat ya know that that
should definitely be enough right so we
might spawn somewhere over here right
well that color will be a spawn point
just because I created it right there
we might spawn somewhere here and then
let's say it's at the middle so the
middle is it yeah this is this is more
closer to middle so we might just um
play that that's the spawn point and so
we've what other things do we have we've
got I'm just looking at all the
resources we have
let's also open one more file and that
will be our textures shapes spawn level
so let's open that we have the Pantone
net all right cool so we've got all
these different files to play around
with all these different tiles rather to
play around with this or okay so let's
just make sure that our exterior I guess
is grass
so grass will make grass will just be
full green right so I might make
something like there might be wolves
eventually it whoops there might be
walls eventually but the most fun was
drawing like the outskirts I guess so
all that will be green and maybe like
whoops keep on let me just fix this yeah
um I'm just trying to act and maybe
something like that you guys will see
what I what I'm talking about in a
minute I'm just helping pace to make
sure that they have the same size you
guys wanted to see level design so hey
yeah well you guys wanted to say yeah
although it's graphical work and I guess
this is graphical work as well I
apologize if this isn't gonna be exactly
symmetrical but whatever alright cool
cool cool beans that is nowhere near
symmetrical let's copy and paste this I
like this more
yeah yeah all right whatever whatever I
might just um hopefully you guys kind of
know what I'm getting at sorry my
phone's going off probably email
notifications okay I hate it when when
like on an iPhone you get a new email
like it doesn't doesn't like show up as
a notification it just like vibrates
well I've always thought my phone on
silent so maybe it doesn't always
library for you guys or whatever but um
for me it always vibrates and I'm like
okay I must have a seven you email cuz
it's not giving you say that that or if
I get paid but like through PayPal but
if I get like money or not necessarily
income more or less um it could also be
like a transaction if there's any PayPal
transaction yeah it alerts me through
pic it's just yeah it just vibrates and
doesn't actually say what's up which is
really annoying but but yeah
and then the other reason is emails so
either I just got some money lost some
money or uh almost likely I got an email
okay so now that this is rubbish damn it
why why you know work let's just clear
all that and then let's copy and paste
this
pixelated and clearly that's not that
good
yeah there we go awesome that Mouse much
better and then down the bottom here we
might sorry I'm I'm kind of a
perfectionist when it comes to um to
this sort of thing so you guys might be
in for some long videos hopefully your
mind because um do mind
dead um well you probably want to go
right ahead on and and unsubscribe
because we're gonna we're going to be
looking through some some of this stuff
in the future
okay so spawn point I want to move that
to about oh I don't know me to do that
all right I'm gonna move the spawn point
to like here alright cool
so what kind of walls have we got okay I
like that wall that's rule one right so
what one's gonna be dis dis gray okay I
put like two rows of wool one or
something to keep our citizens in the
castle all right I just sort but I have
a bit of this going on
yeah so we're just gonna move it and
make sure there's a double-time
just a lot kill kill and then I guess
this will go all the way to here right
correct mr. Chadha correct
all right and you know
there we go and then for here we might
only have one because you know for that
that section the architect was like your
alert will deal with one one wall that
you my computer's gonna like run out of
disk space halfway through this
recording or something
hopefully that actually won't happen all
right so we've made this place
completely symmetrical haven't went oh
well I don't do right and I might put
some portals to other worlds here in the
future all right all right
okay sorry I think that's looking pretty
good
all right that's like our sort of
brownish type area whoops I meant to go
here so obviously floor everywhere but
apart from that wall too
so Walter might be like a darker color
and I just want to pop this like oh this
is my pops um you know justjust just
cool stuff I really like how old games
just had like dead ends and you know
come like this I remember I'm Pokemon
Trading Card Game
yes that was a game for gameboy color
that I had and played a lot when I was a
child and I had like all these like
random places there was no point going
that but um it just had of that look
like a friggin that looks like a baby
like a babe or something awesome let's
just make sure it's a magical day
there's no symmetrical I'll tell ya
that's much more right yeah
yeah it is special bad yeah they had um
all these areas and it was really cool
so that's I guess that's the point and
maybe we'll have like a little I've no
idea what this levels to not look like
SARS little be bearable and then finally
I'm just gonna pick a brown color so
like that brown it's gonna be um that's
a very bad brown that's like orange
brown that's red narf that give me Brown
there we go that's a nice brown okay so
that's what that map looks like right
now all the spawn points gone there we
go so yeah awesome alright so now let's
go ahead and define all of these all
these colors and then I'll get out of
your hair for today
alright deal deal so control s will
bring up a little save as fire save a
thing I'm sure you guys are aware of it
also um hit file save as yeah cool so
let's go into our resources levels and
over here we can um spawn that's it it's
born ball court so here in level we
might make a like a public oops
so public static level McCullough spawn
equal new level and
it's obviously going to be in resources
is obvious but it would be in levels so
poor slash levels and then spawn go I
can't today
want okay okay and there you go alright
so it's a static level again we will
have every level every level will be
static because there's only one one
instance of that level possibly
available in our code and then the other
thing that we'll do is over here in tile
with what different um I'm just thinking
of this Tribunal openers probably should
probably be in time so public will make
some numbers so public final static
actually don't really matter but I think
I like becoming static final first
anyone will say in a minute
public final state public static final
whatever and it will be integer and it
will be well we'll make one greater than
right sir spawn grass yes hang on I'm
just sure cuz I'm just trying to think
where it should go so what I'm trying to
do here is I'm trying to it's good to
find every color so if tiled up yeah so
color and then grass then I guess warm
broth right it's born on this across
equals and we'll pick color for it so in
this case it's this color which is I
think is full brain yeah so it's here x
FF 0 0 absolute zero right that's that's
green with an alpha Channel and then
we'll do the rest I think I like doing
this more than putting final off to
static obviously doesn't matter again
personal preference so color and we'll
go spawn edge which we actually use so
I'm just gonna put 0 and then we like
so what else do we have we've got water
to put in the newspaper we will make
mobile user dollars in the leadership it
just nothing out so then we've also got
war one
they've got Walter and one more week
like four so let's quickly get all the
colors for these things so this is wool
one right bunch of eights so this is the
one eight zero eight zero eight zero
Walter is this darker gray which is
three zero three zero three zero oops
that's over here and floor is this
awesome brown color which I spent like
an hour camp which doesn't have any
letters in it look about all the numbers
of blow nine all that can take away
no night so yeah so that's pretty
awesome now that we've defined all the
colors and we need to do it when we
actually go ahead and make out our level
I guess loaded in will have to just
reference these colors and the tile
should work so that's what we'll do next
time we'll actually move on to drawing
our level I guess and and yeah hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit that like button
and I'll see you guys in the next video
bye guys
you